joining me today is the editor of human
progress org and a senior policy analyst
at the Center for Global liberty and
prosperity Marion to be welcome to the
Rubin report thanks for having me I am
very excited to have you on we've met
once before for a dinner but what you're
doing with human progress I think is
just spectacular you guys are actually
promoting good news there is actual good
news and good things happening in the
world and it's seemingly is something
that people don't often talk about so I
think you're doing great work and we're
gonna spend an hour talking about a lot
of the good stuff that is happening but
I always like to start with a little bio
on people so tell me a little bit about
yourself how do you end up working for
human progress well I was born behind
the Iron Curtain
in what was then communist
Czechoslovakia and so from early age I
started to understand the importance of
political and economic freedom we had
neither that you learned it pretty quick
and that's right
and then when the wall came down in 1989
me and my parents went for Christmas in
Vienna that was the first time that you
could actually leave your country and
you could travel abroad yeah as a family
how old were you I was 13 because before
then people still could travel to the
west but they would keep the the
children behind as hostages but now that
the wall came down and comes in
collapsed you could travel anywhere he
wanted so we decided to go to Vienna and
in the moment that we cross the border
into a Western capitalist liberal
democracy it was like stepping out of a
black-and-white movie into a color film
everything was just so much beautiful so
much more beautiful the shops were full
people were smiling there was color
everywhere and so I think that even at
that early stage of my
I started to think about what makes
countries rich what makes countries poor
and that's I think where my interest in
in in all of that started really yeah
tell me a little bit about your your
education
well I went to high school and
undergraduate in Johannesburg South
Africa of all places because when the
wall came down my parents immigrated to
to South Africa they are medical doctors
and so our expertise was was needed so
as a kid I got to see both the fall of
communism and also the fall of apartheid
which is kind of a unique experience and
I'm very glad I had the kind of
childhood are bringing ahead and so I so
I finished my undergraduate at the
University of Witwatersrand in
Johannesburg and then I went to do my
masters and my PhD at st. Andrews in
Scotland yeah well what's it like being
in these places when something is
falling like communism or apartheid
because we seem to live in a time right
now where a lot of people think that
we're watching parts of the West kind of
fall and you've seen some stuff fall yes
I think that's for the most vast
majority of the population in
Czechoslovakia clearly the fall of
communism was a tremendous blessing
there was an immense amount of optimism
about the future and also unavoidable
disappointment with some aspects of the
utopian future that people have imagined
nonetheless just about anybody who
analyzes economics and politics in
central Eastern Europe of the last 25
years concludes that people are much
much better off than they used to be and
I think the similar thing was happening
for a vast majority of South Africans
especially black South Africans who
never had a vote who never had political
rights or most political rights and
apartheid and of course in 1994 South
Africa held its first multiracial
democratic elections and as a
consequence there was also a tremendous
amount of optimism again followed by the
inevitable disappointments as reality
set in
the less it's an extraordinary time of
enthusiasm and optimism and tremendous I
think a sense of brotherhood between
people yeah do you think that's
necessary that sort of utopian vision of
when things are changing that everything
is going to be magically fixed and
better and then as you're saying then
there's that period where you go oh it
didn't everything didn't magically get
fixed at once but you sort of need that
vision to get there you sort of need
that to kind of see in the distance I
think you appeal to a token vision of
the future as you consolidate democracy
in in in the case of in the case of
Eastern Europe and as you consolidate
multiracial democracy in the case of in
the case of South Africa but ultimately
utopianism is the great enemy of of
human progress because I think that
human progress needs to be needs to be
measured in terms of the past rather
than some sort of utopian future human
progress is an incremental process where
you are trying to decide okay is today
better than yesterday and if so that is
progress
but the problems are going to be with us
forever the question is are we actually
improving incrementally in important
areas of human wellbeing on daily basis
is that one of the problems with how we
ingest news because I was telling you
before we started like I went on human
progress this morning and it feels good
to me I mean the the layout of the site
is great and the images and the colors
and all that but like seeing so many
consistently good things trending that
you don't see anywhere else and we're
gonna we're gonna get into many of them
is that just is it hard to get clicks
because people don't like the Oh things
are a little better than yesterday and a
little and long trends when they just
want the the day-to-day craziness and Ed
lines and all that yes III wouldn't be
the first one to point to the nature of
news
the fact that news is about things of
that happen steven pinker
always likes to say yeah you know there
is no journalist standing in the middle
of a city that is at peace
saying you know I'm here in Luanda the
capital of whatever it is Ralph on gol I
think and there is no civil war you know
journalists go to places where terrible
things happen and they report on those
things and so that gives a skewed image
of what is happening in the world if it
bleeds it leads
I mean that is there is a well-known
phenomenon combined with the nature of
the social media certainly I think that
Twitter and and and smartphones make
terrible things immediate and intimate
so you know we were able to watch
tsunami in Japan in real time we saw
destruction and and death of thousands
of people in real-time whereas you know
a couple of decades a few decades ago
and certainly few centuries ago you
would never have known yeah that a
terrible thing has happened on the other
side of the world does that complicate
your work do you think that that people
get information so quickly that then
maybe are making misjudgments because
they're not looking at the sort of long
view of history I'm not sure if it
complicates things
because pessimism is part of human
nature it it also enables us to respond
to the stories in a quicker time to be
able to say on our website at least look
it is true that there was in this
particular case tsunami and people have
died but look at the long-term trends in
terms of people dying and property being
damaged due to extreme weather events or
natural catastrophes and the Train is
trend is declining so we are also able
to use the social media to to respond to
it
the the problem is that the good news
doesn't get picked up yeah as often as
the bad news because the bad news leads
the the good news doesn't yeah and
there's just a psychological component
there might be an evolutionary reason we
focus on the bad things maybe for
survival or something to that effect yes
john tooby and cosmides from university
of is it Southern California at Santa
Barbara yeah yeah they are they are the
pioneers of of evolutionary biology they
believe that our brains have evolved in
at a time in in tens of thousands of
years ago when the world was just a much
more inhospitable place than what it is
today the world where there was only
present danger from other tribes from
wild animals from poisonings and at a
time when life expectancy was very low
and they like to say that our modern
skulls house ancient mines and and and
the kind of psychological responses that
we have evolved for tens of thousands of
years ago are difficult to apply to
modernity which is just so fundamentally
different than what it was until
relatively recently the the key period
here in time history is the last 200 to
250 years when the world really has
changed beyond all recognition yeah so
in a weird way are we almost we as
humans are we almost victims of our own
success I mean that's sort of what it
sounds like
like we've we've done so much good we
have advanced so far that now we're we
nitpick about little things constantly
and think they're massive when yeah
we're not dying of massive we're doing a
lot with disease which we're gonna get
to and a whole bunch of other things
we've made our lives way safer and
extend
our lives and all of these things so
we're almost a victim of all of that
goodness
yes so from an evolutionary perspective
again a research of others not my own
overreaction to a potentially bad thing
happening had a lower cost to the
organism in this case a human being then
under reaction mm-hmm
if you overreact it saw something that
may have been potentially harmful but
you already acted to it but but you
survived whereas if you under reacted to
something that was potentially harmful
then your gene pool ended right there
yeah and so those kids didn't get passed
on so yeah so yes the complexity of the
modern economy the complexity of the
social interactions global trading
system for example is certainly much
greater than what our ancestors were
exposed to and so it is perhaps not
surprising that a lot of people are a
little bit uneasy or continue to be
uneasy yeah then again the website is
there to show people precisely how bad
things were before and how good things
are now so don't get depressed too much
there is a good story to be told about
humanity yeah it's interesting when I go
speak at colleges one of the lines that
I think does actually work with young
people who are you know if they're
protesting and they're screaming about
the patriarchy and evils of capitalism
and all of this stuff I always say to
them you know does anyone in this room
not have it better than their
grandparents and certainly in the United
States but if you live in the Western
world basically everybody does pretty
much I have yet to find someone that
doesn't and I always think that's a
really effective way of getting people
who who are so focused on the negative
to go oh something good must have
happened because you know even though I
like to scream about my victimhood it's
a lot better than what my grandparents
had yes I mean take something like like
a woman's
quality or gay quality or even caring
about environment and and and animal
rights or animal welfare I should say
Jonathan Hyde from New York University
says that capitalism actually
fundamentally transforms our sense of
values because our priorities I should
maybe say because when we are extremely
poor which is to say the first 99.9% of
Homo sapiens on earth right the primary
objective of any individual human being
was was to survive you had to somehow
get hold of enough calories to make it
to the next day you had to somehow avoid
being murdered by somebody who wanted
your stuff yeah you had to somehow
protect your family you had to keep away
from cold from heat etc but in the last
200 years or so our incomes have
skyrocketed the world is roughly
speaking adjusted for inflation I can't
say this often enough because ya always
attack but you are not adjusting for
yeah no of course we are just about
inflation adjusted for inflation the
world average is roughly 12 times better
off than what it was in in 1820 hmm so
we have become much richer and when you
no longer have to worry about things
like survival you start caring about
things like the nature of the society
that you live in the fairness of
treatment of your fellow human beings
you start caring about women equality as
I said your self caring about gay rights
you start caring about animal protection
and environmental protection so so in
that sense the the tremendous increase
in in incomes and and general wealth of
the society has also contributed to
creating an much fair
and much more egalitarian society so
capitalism isn't all evil is that what
you're telling me
people who think have it all some she is
evil I I highly recommend that they
visit Cuba they visit Venezuela they
visit North Korea in countries which
have which have taken deliberately a
step in the opposite direction
capitalism has its problems liberal
democracy has its problems and it is our
task to try to fix these problems on the
margins mm-hmm
but to throw out the economic and social
underpinnings of modernity of this of
this extraordinary age of abundance
would be a mistake are you shocked at
the amount of people in the West that
seemingly want to do just that
no I'm much I'm not even shocked by the
fact that in Eastern Europe where I'm
from people who are in their early teens
and into the late teens people who have
never experienced Communists and people
who are born after the fall of the
Berlin Wall
are now embracing socialist ideas or at
least those socialist ideas are now
increasingly popular amongst young
people which day which has certainly
aren't amongst people of my generation
what do you chalk that up to you because
I don't think it's just that they didn't
experience is it is it is it is it just
that utopian dream that we all have or
is it just that it all sounds good the
endless cry of equality which of course
never turns out to be equality it all is
just if you don't want to really deeply
think about a system well then communism
or socialism is pretty good
well not containment like to say that
that every generation needs to be
educated in the benefits of freedom and
I think that even founding fathers were
talking about something about you know
we're always one generation away from
tyranny now what that meant was to say
that there is something perhaps in human
nature that drags us back into that
into that tribal socialistic mindset now
there are a lot of different theories
about that one possible theory is that
actually as we grow up we grow up in a
in the only functioning communist a
communist Society or communist
institution which is the family in a
family especially a nuclear family
people share wildly children are not
expected to earn the breakfast by I
don't know
bringing home the bacon or whatever you
know things get shared very very equally
and so forth and and that can work on a
on a sort of nuclear family level
mmm-hmm the further you go the less it
works I mean it what you are prepared to
do for your children is not the same
what you are prepared to do for your
cousins it's not the same which you are
prepared for your second cousins for
your fellow citizens and for that matter
for people on the opposite side of the
world
and so the the fact that we are able to
conduct our affairs on on a along these
along these socialist lines in a nuclear
family doesn't then translate into into
the society as a whole so that may be
one reason another reason may be that
that there is within human beings within
human psychology a tendency to want to
bring down people who have gotten too
far up mm-hmm
if you are thinking about tribal society
or or these roaming groups of
hunter-gatherers of say between 50 150
people where everybody you didn't want
all the women and all the foods to be
monopolized by the one alpha male so
they usually there was some sort of a
combination of an alliance made by other
males to bring this alpha male down so
there would be greater sharing
and and that was good for the alpha male
- right I mean he wanted to survive
himself if he survived it is alright I
mean I mean in in amongst the chimps and
so forth the the alpha male does usually
and very poorly mm-hmm
so that may be another reason another
reason may be that in hunter-gathering
society some of the food would be shared
equally there was a for example if you
killed an animal
there was no refrigeration you couldn't
store it there was no accumulation of
wealth in that sense mm-hmm
and so things did get shared amongst the
members of the group plus there was no
accumulation of wealth because because
you were constantly moving so whatever
you acquired was limited to whatever you
were able to carry on the back on your
back yeah
so yes the difference is between people
at least to the extent that we are
experiencing now is something that is
probably quite new yeah from an
evolutionary standpoint so all of these
reasons ensure that and many more ensure
that young people or rather every
generation needs to be explicitly
educated in why the economy that we have
today which is so different from what
our ancestors have experienced is
actually good for us free trade is a
very good example
free trade contributes second growth and
yet every generation you have a new push
for protectionism again the complexity
of the economy has outpaced
our ability to understand it without
explicit learning yeah all right so
let's talk about a whole bunch of these
trends that are happening right in front
of our eyes but as you said they're
happening incrementally so people don't
necessarily focus on them enough well
I'll let you kick off the person what do
you what do you think is the most
encouraging worldwide trend at the
moment
well what's exciting you the most well
so the human progress is Anna Bishop
unabashedly about it's a human centric
which is to say that we considered the
welfare and the flourishing of a
human being all human beings to be to be
really important of primary importance
yeah that's an interesting distinction
because you didn't call it earth
progress.org right I mean the idea was
that this is so that humans can figure
out the best place the best way to live
here and hopefully that's good for the
earth too but that humans actually are
number one here yes we can certainly
talk late in the show about is it
possible for humans to coexist with the
earth and the animals and and what can
we do to make sure that that actually
happens but human progress is a
humanistic project mm-hmm and clearly
there is no more fundamental aspect to
human flourishing than staying alive and
here we have seen tremendous improvement
prior to 1800 s life expectancy around
the world was anywhere between 25 and 30
years since time immemorial mm-hmm
as late as 1953 as late as 1900 in the
richest countries of the world life
expectancy was only 50 years today
globally it's 70 years in the United
States is 78 years and in places like
Japan it's 88 years
so wait let's let's not gloss over that
as those were some powerful numbers so
in 1900 the average life expectancy was
50 years sobei none of the in rich
countries in rich countries in rich
countries this is that's even more
impressive so to speak how we've
advanced it so you're saying basically
in the hundred 20 years since then or so
we've extended it by 20 years about
scaling by 30 years in in the West
Indian countries and by about an end and
an average person today say somebody
living Malaysia
lives 20 years longer than rich people
did in 1900 yeah that's incredible so in
a hundred 20 years in in rich Western
countries we extended life 30 years in a
hundred 20 I mean that's that's that's
almost unfathomable actually it's it's
it's wonderful yeah so that's the
thing is that you know people want to
stay alive because they they enjoy it
yeah can you give me some of the markers
of how we actually did that well one
thing is decline in violence which again
Steven Pinker has written a whole book
about you know rates of people dying in
in wars I have have declined certainly
since the end of the Second World War
today for the first time in human
history there is no hot conflict between
two states that have declared war on
each other mhm so we still have a frozen
conflict between North Korea and the
United States we have we have the
Russian invasion of the eastern Ukraine
but even then Russia and Ukraine are not
officially at the war so this this old
concept of two countries
you know declaring war on each other and
then going to Wars is actually has
actually well at this stage it has
disappeared yeah it would almost be
unfathomable these days where two
warring countries with full-on wars were
invading each other in the traditional
sense it would almost be hard to imagine
what that would look like now that is
very one could cause that yeah hopefully
it stays that way now one thing to
remember about about about human
progress is that there is nothing
predetermined about it it is not linear
there are obviously things which can go
terribly wrong in the 20th century you
have the first world war possibly the
most unnecessary major conflict in in
recent centuries followed by the Second
World War the Holocaust the gulag and
what have you but the remarkable thing
about human progress and humanity as a
whole its is that it is quite robust at
the end of the twentieth century life
expectancy was still longer than what it
was at the beginning of the 20th century
we were still consuming more calories
more people went to school and so on and
so forth in spite of the 20th century
being actually quite violent yeah anyhow
since the since the end of the Second
World War a world has gotten
progressively more peaceful then of
course you have medical breakthroughs
well let's pause on the violence part
for just a sec because I think it's one
of those things where you can say that
to people and you can talk all about the
wars that don't exist anymore and that
there are in you know genocides the way
there were on all of those things it
does though admitting that some bad
things are still happening I think
people just don't buy it they see school
shootings or they see you know a riot
here or something happening all over
place and they just automatically
believe things are getting worse that
sort of gets us to where we started
about how technology is a part of this
but how difficult is that for you just
to get the truth across to people and
have them actually accept it while at
the same time they're looking at you
know a shooting or this or that that
they can just quickly see online yeah
you've got to look at the long term
trends and and try to figure out whether
things in fact are getting worse or
whether this is a blip you know the line
of progress again it's not linear it is
jagged yeah and and there is no once
again there is no guarantee that that
that things will continue to improve so
you have to look at long term trends I
think the Atlantica ran a story a few
months ago after the latest school
shooting showing that actually the
number of kids dying at schools horrible
as it aids yeah have been on a decline
so yes so long-term trends and then
having journals to actually report to
those long-term trends that that would
be key yeah so so violence is one thing
it will live in less violent times the
second thing is that the medical
breakthroughs were absolutely
fundamental and here I would point
simply to two things one was vaccination
guy called Jenner in MIT I believe mid
18th century England
notice that milkmaids didn't get didn't
get smallpox
now smallpox was absolutely horrifying
disease I mean your body would be
covered with these with the hostels and
they would and and you know 80% of kids
who got it died up to 60% of at all
who got it who died you know died in in
18th century France it was estimated 95%
of the population got smallpox at one
point of their life or another and
general notice that milkmaids didn't get
smallpox that's because they got a
milder version of the pox from cows hmm
and so he started inoculating people
with the pox from the cow and because
the latin word for cow is vodka
our word vaccination comes from from
that and that was a major improvement
the other thing that happened was was
that humanity discovered the the germ
theory of disease we didn't know that
disease was spread via germs people had
all sorts of weird ideas about humors in
the body and mere somatic theories and
what-have-you and it was all nonsense
but the upshot of us being so ignorant
about how disease spreads was that
people for example didn't wash their
hands and you can imagine a farmer is
using human excrement in order to
fertilize his fields and comes home and
sits down to dinner
you can imagine what sort of disease is
level yeah now juice funny enough who
washed their hands as part of their
religious rituals tended to fall less
sick and died at a lower rate than the
rest of the of the European population
but once again because people are so
ignorant about how this is spread they
assumed it was magic which again led to
pogroms and discrimination against the
Jews but even doctors didn't doctors
also didn't change their clothes because
the more blood and gore you had on your
clothes the more it signified to the
potential patient that you are a doctor
in great demand right right so so so
doctors were actually a massive reason
or
one of the major reasons why disease
spread they went from dissecting corpses
to delivering babies introducing
pathogen into into into the body of a of
a mother and and all that stopped
basically after discovery of the germ
theory of disease and and child
mortality maternal mortality started to
decline and life expectancy showed up as
a result yeah what what else is going on
with the diseases of today that were
we're getting close to eradicating some
things that still exist right well we
are very close to eradicating polio
there are some what's called wild cases
of polio in in places like the Congo of
course we have we have made hiv/aids or
rather we have we have created drugs
that no longer make hiv/aids a death
sentence mm-hmm which you know
considering it only took from 1980 when
we first started talking about hiv/aids
to about 1994 1995 when the first
antiretroviral drugs came along only 14
or 15 years that's a remarkable
accomplishment I mean people have lived
with smallpox for millennia so we have
we have we were able to do that now the
other thing which is quite extraordinary
is that cancer rates are declining now
the reason why that's so interesting is
that incidences of cancer increase with
age so as people grow older and on
average we continue to increase our life
expectancy right chances of you
contracting or developing cancer not
contracting but developing cancer yeah
get much higher cancer is basically just
cells dividing during a normal process
of human body existing but the more
subdivision of cells you get the more
likely it is that one of them is going
to go crazy and start subdividing
without control
and cause cancer and you're gonna die
and the fact that cancer rates for men
and women are declining certainly in
rich countries even though life
expectancy is shooting up that's again
an extraordinary and extraordinary
achievement because of early detection
because of better drugs now with Chris
Burke as nine the the gene editing
system we are probably going to be able
to focus on personalized medicines so we
are going to be able to create drugs
specifically for one individual or group
of individuals who share can you explain
CRISPR a little bit just for for those
that are you know you don't to give me a
major information but like sort of the
most simple explanation of it I was
reading something on the side today
about Chris Berg
yeah well it's it's a gene editing
technique which is to say that
hypothetically and hopefully we're not
very far from from that from that time
you'll be able to splice out of the
genome to cut out from the genome genes
which are responsible for congenital
diseases which would be which would be a
very nice it would be very nice to know
that if a child gets born it won't
develop multiple sclerosis twenty years
down the line and die in in terrible
pain so these are the sorts of things
that we could do with CRISPR yeah I want
to move on to the environment but is
there anything else I mean education is
the obvious example obviously eighty
percent of the world is literate whereas
most of the time people were not
literate there is now a gender parity
between boys and girls pretty much on
average in the world again something to
be happy about because historically
girls were kept from education at a
higher rate than boys I mean even in
Afghanistan and now girls are allowed to
go to school which again is a wonderful
thing and nutrition I would really like
to end with nutrition which is to say
that famine has disappeared from the
world
side of war zones we all remember those
images of starving children with
inflated bellies in Ethiopia in the
early 1980s and that's that's pretty
much disappeared and hunger was
basically a normal human condition
throughout our history and today and
average African consumes as many
calories as the Portuguese did in the
early 1960s hmm just about everywhere in
the world people are consuming more
calories than then what what the USDA
recommends should be the average intake
and in in Africa day they are certainly
reaching that threshold and Africa is
important because that's really where
absolute poverty continues to be a major
problem I I think it's fair to say that
absolute poverty is going to is ending
as a global problem it is now going to
remain as a as a si as an African
problem that is concentrated in a couple
of African country in in a few African
countries including places like the
Congo all right so let's shift to the
environment if you listen to the news
it's getting hotter everybody's freaking
out about everything we don't have clean
water all of these things calm me down
well I don't want to get into a debate
on into the debate over over the signs
of global warming I'll leave it to the
specialists certainly I do acknowledge
that there is a consensus that the world
is warming whether it is warming at a
too high rate or a luke warming rate and
where it's heading obviously prediction
of the future is that's the most
difficult thing I'm going to leave that
to specialists into scientists yeah just
very quickly on that though is it
possible that in some of the places that
it's warming it's actually good that
it's warming well suddenly there's this
this one scientist from Holland called
professor tall has calculated the likely
costs and benefits of global warming
until 2018 or so and he thought that
because of the growing weaker because of
the longer growing season we'll be able
to actually bring in more more more food
girl more food we also thought that
there's also some evidence
the world is greening as a result of
more co2 in the atmosphere but I do
acknowledge I want to make it very clear
any hate mail to you or to me I'm going
to get hate mail either way knowledge
away I want to acknowledge that there
are serious concerns and and I'm I'm
basically a guy who is a Tecna optimist
I want to look for solutions to these
problems rather than what I don't want
to do is to stop economic development I
don't want to stop economic development
in developing countries because it's
extremely important
that's that people who are very very
poor should not be very very poor it's
very important that if a woman in Angola
or in Zambia has a premature birth she
should be able to have an access to a to
an incubator that is run on a on a on an
electricity grid that is not going to
collapse for example okay that that
people care can air-conditioned their
homes let's say in Africa or they can
they can keep themselves warm in in
Argentina basically that that is my my
goal not to stop economic development
that is particularly if true of of poor
countries but I also think that it
applies to rich countries if if we can
make life more comfortable for people I
I see no III think it would be very
difficult especially within the
Democratic contact context to stop that
now look at what's happening in in
macrons Paris we've seen riots yeah way
that that country has and hasn't seen
since the 1960s why is that
that's because the environmental
concerns of the French elite Makran
included are bumping against
the living standards and limitations on
the living standards of ordinary French
men and women if you increase the price
of electricity dramatically in order to
make people cut down on electricity it's
also going to reduce their both their
comfort but also the standard of living
you're going to put additional taxes on
this that and the other cars gasoline
what have you eventually people are
going to get upset and are going to
start voting for some very unpleasant
people mm-hmm and this is something that
we see happening throughout Europe now
there are many different reasons why
people vote for for unpleasant political
parties but a fundamental feeling that
that standards of living in Europe are
stagnating and that they are being taxed
to a point where I actually have to go
out and protest in the streets burn
hundreds of cars man basically vandalize
the Arc de Triomphe there so these
things are happening so what I want to
do is to sort of navigate a middle
course between between concerns of the
environment and and and continued
economic development and continued
prosperity and I think that the answer
could potentially be found in technolog
team ISM as I would call it so I would
consider fracking to be a good example
of Technol optimism okay burning of one
unit of natural gas produces half as
much co2 emissions as burning of coal so
I think it would make a lot of sense to
burn more natural gas than coal but our
friends on the environmental side hate
that because it still fossil fuels okay
so let's forget about fossil fuels let's
have nuclear energy okay last time
anybody has died from a nuclear accident
was in Chernobyl because the communist
leadership cut corners when it came to
safety and there was a breakdown of
chain-of-command and whatever and there
was this this accident where where
dozens of people died but since then not
a single person has died as a result of
nuclear accidents including in Fukushima
which is the most recent one so nuclear
energy is a perfect example of producing
a lot of energy without any co2
emissions our our friends in the
environmentalist movement please no they
are not let's take another example say
fertilizer let's say that we can
genetically engineer crops to need less
fertilizer and less pesticides why do we
want less fertilizer and less pesticides
because when those flow into rivers and
then into oceans they can have a
negative consequence for wildlife so
ideally we would like to use less
fertilizer less pesticide so imagine
that through GMOs through genetic
engineering we could produce crops that
that that don't require pesticides and
and fertilizer are our friends in the
environment will all be happy no they
hate they hate those every single time
that we offer as techno optimists we
offer a gradual move in the right
direction which cumulatively could have
a massive impact on quality of life on
the Environmental Protection and so
forth you know the answer is always no
so what so it's interesting because when
when you started talking about this
there's this immediate hesitancy because
I think everyone if you talk about
climate at all people think you're gonna
get slammed and I can tell you the most
hate that I ever got on the show was
when I had Alex Epstein on and wrote a
book called the moral case for fossil
fuels and uh he wasn't denying climate
science he was just saying that fossil
fuels in his estimation are still the
best way to advance human prosperity
going forward so it's interesting you
you immediately said you didn't want to
go too far down that road because it
just opens up the the hate and all that
but but the in essence what you're
saying is
that we're having to fight the
environmentalists on what you would
prescribe as the best ways to move the
environment forward that that's pretty
fascinating so how do you get through to
these people then I well I don't know
I'm trying one of the things I'm trying
to explain to a lot of my friends is
that actually prosperity and economic
development can be a friend of the
environment that's because of this
concept of environmental Kuznets curve
now that's just a fancy way of saying
that when people grow richer they are
willing to spend more money on clean
environment and protection of animals
how do I know that because in in well
it's not just stats which show it but
also look at the real life examples when
the economy collapsed in Zimbabwe the
first thing the people did in order to
survive was to start slaughtering
animals in the wild shooting zebras for
meat shooting elephants for tusks and
and the environment took a huge knock in
Venezuela when the economy collapsed
both socialist countries by the way but
never mind in Venezuela when the economy
collapsed
people started slaughtering animals in
the zoo the only way you can survive if
it's a choice between the life of an
antelope and the survival of a child you
know exactly what to do and so economic
development making people richer is
actually a very good way of
accomplishing this environmental Kuznets
curve when people grow rich they start
caring about the air they breathe they
start caring about welfare of animals
and so on and so forth because those are
from the perspective of the survival of
the human being luxury goods and we're
already seeing some very interesting
things happening around the world for
example and the forest coverage of of
the earth is still declining by about
0.08 percent per year but it is
declining primarily if not exclusively
in poor countries
and especially in Africa and also Latin
America but it is increasing in rich
countries afforestation is taking place
there are more forests being grown and
in China we are seeing huge amount of
afforestation because the country is now
richer than what it used to be so
through economic development we can do
that through economic development we can
also we can also start protecting more
of our marine life by creating exclusion
zones against fishing and so forth how
can we do that why is that connected to
economic development well because if you
for example you can well not only do you
have more technological ways of
monitoring who is breaking the rules but
also you can still get access to the
food you want through aquaculture
mmm-hmm okay so countries which are
richer are able to are able to get their
food from from aquaculture rather than
from from ordinary shore fishing so when
it comes to these solutions which by the
way I mean what you just said there it's
pretty mind-blowing that in much of the
world it's getting greener you know I
mean that's people just don't think
about that we just sort of just don't
accept that that's real most of this do
you see that we have to have a sort of
public and private partnership on how we
move forward on these things should most
of this come from governments should it
come from private corporations should it
come from individual people I mean that
seems to be what a lot of the debate is
also about well I think that the reefs
that the evidence for the efficacy of
government spending when it comes to
science when it comes to scientific
research for example it's not all that
persuasive I don't think that
governments are particularly good at
spending money on scientific research
meaning that the research is shoddy or
just that they throw money at things and
then just nothing comes of it
yet that that would be that would be
part of reason I am a believer in in in
private companies doing their own
research driven by the profit motive for
example energy inputs into production of
anything from a can of coke to bottle of
water are cost money a companies
actually do have an incentive at profit
incentive to try to limit the amount of
resources they use in order to produce
any type of good in the 1970s between
1970s and today the number of cans of
coke that you could get from a pound of
aluminum has actually increased by
something like 40% that's because
companies don't want to spend money they
don't have to spend on electricity on
spending money or natural resources and
and raw materials and what-have-you and
so what we are actually seeing is that
the number of dollar dollars per what
the amount of the amount of energy we
need in order to produce a dollar of
output is actually declining and that
that's happening naturally through the
process of profit maximization on the
parts of corporations now that doesn't
mean that there is absolutely no need
for any kind of regulations we don't
want corporations to be to be dumping
toxic materials in our pristine rivers
and what have you but but what I am
saying is that is that corporations in
search for profit are actually very good
at coming up with innovative solutions
to environmental problems yeah it's part
of the problem here also that different
countries that are at different stages
of their evolution of their economies
and everything else mede different
things need wildly different things
what's happening in China now with
growth is very different than what's
happening in the United States or or
India or any of these countries
I have have two that are often putting
out more co2 and emissions and things
like that they're going through their
industrial or evolutions we already did
it so that we have an unequal playing
field when it comes to some of it yes so
that is a well-known notion within the
economic development that as a country
starts on a path to industrialization
its damage to the environment increases
but once again it reaches that that
inflection point and then it starts to
decrease as people become rich enough to
start to appreciate nice environment
ninety percent of the plastics that are
entering our oceans come from eight
rivers they are all in the developing
world in Africa and in Asia the
contribution of Western advanced
economies to plastic pollution of the
oceans is negligible precisely because
we are able to spend more money and
effort and thought on how not to do it
what would you say to the people that
would say our time is up here or the
evolution of humanity is that we've got
to go to the stars that eventually will
have to get off this this mortal coil
and do it again somewhere else well
first of all it is very important to
remember that pessimism about humanity's
future has been with us since these
since the dawn of writing from from
antiquity and ancient poems and epics
you know the the after all the flood
what is it about the flood is about
closing the world round a depressing
population that that that went array the
Cato the Elder writing second century BC
thought that Rome was finished because
you know the the young were corrupted
and women had loose morals and men were
too effeminate to fight wars and this is
when Rome was just a
whole town in you know with fewer with a
few provinces in Italy Rome continue to
expand for the next three to four
hundred years but he was just very early
he was just very early but but you can
see every generation thinks that that
that we are especially as we grow older
we think that the world is entering a
period of decline whereas in fact what
we are do we are projecting our own
physical decline onto the world but so
far those those warnings about the
imminent collapse of humanity have
always been proven wrong as thomas
babington macaulay in nineteen century
british politician and writer has
written on what basis is it that having
seen all this progress that we have made
behind us we see nothing but misery in
front of us paraphrasing but that's the
essence of what he said and i think he's
absolutely right yeah so we've we've
done the diseases were eradicating we're
doing a lot of good on the environment
or at least have have some options now
we do have options yes yeah what else
what else should we be hitting on to
give people some some positivity to
think about well i think my pet peeve is
that i think that people don't read
enough history aren't enough versed in
in in history how life really used to be
like before and i wish that people would
spend more time thinking about what i'm
doing on a daily basis and asking
themselves would i be able to do this in
the past
mm-hm I just had a crown of put in or a
root canal operation with anesthetic and
it was it was not something and it
wasn't a particularly pleasant right but
but but it was better than it would have
been 100 years ago 100 or 200 years ago
you have to have it you know somebody
would have to pull it out of your out of
your mouth and so so that's one thing I
think that people and I think that if
people understand history better and how
life truly was quite
until very recent times again we are 300
thousand years old but at the time of
abundance is roughly 200 years old
250 years old maybe they will be more
grateful and for the things that we have
and hopefully they will be more
appreciative and more supporting of the
institutions which underpin modernity
liberal democracy with all of its warts
with all of its imperfections it is
still functioning better than putin's
russia or or arrogance turkey
free-market capitalism doesn't have its
problems yes
we shouldn't socialize costs of banking
for example and privatized and privatize
gains from wall street banking but again
it is the best it is the best creator of
wealth known to humankind and so
throwing it out because there are
imperfections on the margins that we
should be working on to improve would be
a great mistake so yes
appreciation of the past gratitude for
the present hopefulness for the future
those are the steps in I think in the
right direction that my friend is an A+
ending to an interview and for more on
Marion and the incredible work that
Think Progress is doing you guys can
check out thinkprogress.org
[Music]